c'est une véritable téléréalité dans la
réalité qui est en train de se passer
ces derniers jours suivie par des
milliers de fans car la mort aux accusés
de sorcellerie contre plusieurs
candidats des marseillais dont sa
meilleure amie maeva ghanam
je sais qu'un cas d'un match qu'on nous
fait de la sorcellerie des poupées
vaudou hier soir dans tpm paix nous
revenions sur cette affaire en recevant
le blogueur marc plata à l'origine de la
diffusion des vidéos qui mettent en
cause carla n'a pas nié le fait que ce
soit si les auxerrois qui a été reportée
sur mes réseaux sociaux tous au même
moment c'est le père de carla mots qui
réagissait sur un live instagram d'une
grande violence en se désolidarisant
complètement de sa fille
je suis dégoûté mais alors que tous les
marseillais a appelé au boycott de carla
un retournement de situation incroyable
a eu lieu dans la soirée avec cette
vidéo de maeva ghanam je tiens à
m'excuser auprès de carla je suis donc
la vérité toute cette histoire est
fausse
une vidéo qui pose question sur twitter
beaucoup dénoncent une manipulation mais
aujourd'hui maeva retirer sa vidéo en
adressant ce message
oui c'est sa voix et carla me l'a confié
hier au téléphone j'ai réagi à chaud
renvoyant le désespoir de kevin car hier
soir j'étais avec lui comme une façon de
préserver car là malgré sa culpabilité
mais qui croire dans cette histoire le
scandale est il était inventée de toutes
pièces
alors c'est vrai que ça rebondit cette
nuit avec cette histoire de sorcellerie
qu'a fait énormément parler hier c'était
très très nombreux d'ailleurs à regarder
l'émission
et cette histoire alors le scandale at
il été inventée de toutes pièces non non
on va avoir la réponse
magali maria vous connaissez tout la
ferme à gagner car l'amour où elle est
dans votre agence ouais d'accord
julien mannon donc ils sont 11e alors
qu'il est ce que la première question
que se posent tous les téléspectateurs
c'est est-ce que ça a été d'ailleurs on
va faire un tour de plus si vous n'avez
nous dire après d'ailleurs oui gilles
verdez dit non pour l'instant bien
entendu que ça n'a pas été inventée de
toute pièce ça a été un buzz orchestré
ces formes et c'est grave johnny moi
c'est pas un buzz orchestré d'ailleurs
elle a retiré ses excuses elle a été
mise sous pression toute la nuit toute
la matinée
magali giat de vous entendre parce que
vous n'êtes pas innocents sur cette
affaire mais je laisserai vous et
arrêtez d'abord bien entendu que la
production agit bien entendu que les
marseillais ont fait bloc
il ya eu une volonté si vous voulez de
dire que ce n'était rien mais je
maintiens que il ya eu cette affaire de
sorcellerie qui n'est pas la seule dans
la télé réalité 2 sous b vrai
les poser les questions celle berne est
bien entendu vous êtes là pour ça et oui
alors j'ai contacté des candidats des
marseillais qui m'ont dit qu'en fait
kevin donc est le compagnon de carla
sera examiné en urgence à dubaï pour
tenter de convaincre maeva de s'excuser
de dire que toute cette histoire était
fausse
apparemment la ligne de défense de carla
c'est de dire qu'elle aurait été victime
d'extorsion de fonds et qu'en fait elle
aurait fait ça sous la pression de cette
fameuse voyante qu'elle voyait depuis
ses 18 ans mais la candidate que j'ai
contacté et m'a dit que même si elle
avait été sous la pression de cette
voyante elle aurait pu lui demander des
choses moins grave le premier sac elle
lui a demandé des choses très graves et
à l'encontre de son entourage
donc certains candidats des marseillais
trouve ça très louche alors oui ticket
où ils vous connaissez moi je pense que
kevin donc qui est le compagnon de carla
il est parti à dubaï
il s'est déplacé parce qu'il s'est dit
pas de notes vocales pas de textos rien
écrit il n'y a aucune trace
je vais aller mettre un petit coup de
pression parce que j'ai peut-être des
bye j'ai peut-être des doses contre vous
aussi donc maintenant vous allez vous
taire sur ma femme vous allez arrêter de
faire des histoires pas possible sur les
réseaux sociaux
et ça a fonctionné puisque maeva amis
justement ce message en s'excusant
qu'elle a effectivement tu as raison mon
âge il retiré par la suite mais tout de
même aujourd'hui on est en train de se
dire est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est pas vrai alors qu'à voir gilles
vous saurez si sadi vrai si sadi faut
absolument je la connais magali il va te
défoncer year by zoé je ne marche pas
aujourd'hui comme ça kim
moi je pense qu'apple avait suivi cette
affaire ou pas oui elle fut suivie et
ben comme tout le monde mais je pense qu
a pas de fumée sans feu après je suis
contre l'acharnement qui assure carla
parce qu'il ya toujours la présomption
d'innocence
maintenant c'est pas nouveau on sait que
beaucoup de stars que ce soit katy perry
bien de ces ont vendu leur âme au diable
il ya beaucoup de c'est quoi cette
histoire de sorcellerie vous avez déjà
fait appel à sûr c'est que jamais de la
vie ouhlala loin de là mon dieu mais
est-ce que vous connaissiez cette
histoire peut-être qu'elle a essayé de
faire de faire appel à cette voyante
c'est qu'elle a été peut-être prises au
piège après je sais pas alors et du
chantage je sais pas je connais pas la
fin de cette histoire apparemment vous
les connaissez ces personnes isolées
connaît bien sûr parce que dans votre
chouchou
bonjour je ne sais pas qui vous êtes et
est donc oui non mais vous les
connaissez donc moi s car là c'est pas
forcément à ma grande copine mais elle
mérite pas cet acharnement
j'ai besoin d'un cascadeur est hélas non
mais je pense que dans dans leur univers
à eux je pense que le buzz fait partie
intégrante de thé ça de bala je pense
que c'est ils peuvent pas venir sans
donc je ne sais pas ce qui est vrai ce
qu'il faut parce que a priori on n'en
sait rien maintenant les vidéos qu'on
est venu hier elle semble bien réelle
bien bien réel maintenant de là à y
croire moi je pense que c'est plus un
bleu à buzz orchestré plutôt qu'autre
chose mais sûrement que la papesse de la
télé réalité est la réponse alors marc
batta le blogueur qui avait donc mis en
ligne ces ses vidéos il était très très
étonné de ce nouveau rebondissement
regardez s'est montré très surpris salut
à tous la famille instagram j'espère que
vous allez bien je vous fais pas souvent
de story on a cassé internet un frérot
ans on n'a qu'à internet pour de vrai
hier autour de mende situation de fou
malade vidéo de maeva en train de
pleurer bébé
baby ski vois pas ce qu'on en fait après
l'asie cl
les vidéos c'est elle et ils fument quoi
comme drogue encore là et donc pour
soutenir ses propos et de la pas hésité
à dévoiler un nouvel enregistrement
audio dans lequel carla moreau s'en
prendrait une nouvelle fois à cette
maybach
alors oui j'ai lu arrêté il a été un peu
il a été précurseur puis après il a été
un peu dépassé
et c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de sites
d'information qui sont basées à dubaï
qui traite de télé réalité parce que les
stars sont là bas et sur beaucoup de
sites on parlait même d'une intervention
de la police de dubaï de trucs jacut
réaliste voilà j'ai pas pu les confirmer
ça ça me semble faux mais en tout cas il
ya une sorte de surenchère et c'est vrai
que honnêtement les audio il n'invente
pas voilà alors magali berda et
apprendre à la vie de gevrey à voir
lille et oui nicolas pernikoff isabelle
morini-bosc irradie une maille et vous
qu'est ce que vous dites de cette
affaire a coûté nous vraiment la vraie
histoire et on vous dira si on vous
croit ou pas en fait car là
effectivement est allé voir une voyante
dès l'âge de 17 ans ça fait 17 ans
qu'elle consulte cette personne lui a
donné un million trois cent mille euros
et lui a donné pratiquement un million
deux cent mille euros en quatre ans à
dire donc à lui donne l eau des 300000
euros par an à saint louis
en fait elle s'est un peu laissé
dépasser je pense parce que le départ
est allé la voir elle reconnaît elle le
dit les clients avec mais parce que hier
je voulais justement mourir là tu
comment cette personne peut avoir en
quatre ans un million trois cent mille
euros a donné une voyante
je pense que c'est pas le sujet c'est
ses revenus
elle faisait des paiements tous les mois
c'est à dire sept personnes tous les
mois elle lui verser de l'argent et
après ça a dégénéré effectivement en
chantage extorsions de fonds et cetera
mais effectivement carla était
consciente qu'elle allait voir une
voyante effectivement oui il ya eu des
notes audio qui ont été faites car là ne
renie pas ses notes audio l'avouer donc
ya pas de montage donc d'aucun ses
vidéos ses notes audio où elle dit où
elle elle dit voilà qu'elle voudrait
qu'il arrive malheur à d'autres au
contraire voilà ces marseillais donc
julien mannon et maeva ont été
énormément peiné parce que vous les
connaissez tout ça on sait que c'est des
gens qui sont rigolos nous font rire et
ne pas ces gens bienveillants les
marseillais sont connus pour être une
famille et sont retrouvés vraiment très
peiné par ce qu'ils ont entendu des
notes audio de carla extrêmement
violente sur leurs enfants
effectivement il y avait près avec le
petit de jessica et thibault et le
petite manon et julien et c'est donc à
corps ça les a vraiment est ce que dans
et dieu sait qu'elles sont adorables les
hameaux et c'est vrai que julien par
exemple senti qu'il ne s'exprime jamais
sur les polémiques qui s'exprimait que
deux fois quand on a agressé entre
guillemets ses enfants sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont réagi comme ça parce
qu'ils ont été tellement choqué c'était
tellement violent les notes
j'en ai eu vent dans mes donc non vérité
c'est que la vérité la vérité sur
aujourd'hui et pourquoi carla maeva
pardon c'est pour elle a dit que c'était
fou alors ça va kevin effectivement
installé à dubaï pour la voir alors
qu'un mari attend déchets verts parce
que là pour parler d'eux en dresser des
personnages de qu'il espère
vous y donc maeva seyssel voilà qui
était qui a été touchée la sorcellerie
et de son mari c'est kevin une raison
ticket une guedj qui est partie à dubaï
pour aller voir carla dans le bon allez
voir maeva pour lui dire de pas ses amis
sa famille des marseillais pour leur
expliquer que sa femme
enfin sa femme samedi matin carla est
allé donc ça c'est une information
d'aller déposer une plainte samedi matin
pour avec plusieurs griefs donc chantage
atteinte à l'intimité de la vie privée
par enregistrement aux captations abus
de faiblesse et contre la voyante
ah oui et escroquerie à lardy contre le
bruit beaucoup de temps a déposé samedi
matin c'est ce qu'elle est ce qu'ils ont
expliqué à kevin carla a eu maeva hier
soir pendant une heure au téléphone et
maeva qui est très très touché par cette
situation parce que c'est sa meilleure
amie
effectivement abandonnés assez
d'immenses j'ai peut-être fait une
erreur je ne sais pas qu'est ce qui se
passe mais les notes audio
je les ai entendus car là affirmé à
maeva oui c'est moi qui ait fait ces
notes audio mais je les ai faits sous la
contrainte
maintenant les marseillais étant une
famille quand même très soudé se sont
dits oui ou non il ya deux versions soit
la première c'est carla a fait ça sous
la menace soit elle l'a fait
volontairement au gp vous avec la boule
à thé mondiaux
jouer les pompiers de service mais c'est
du pipeau complet vous avez arrêté vous
avez pas fini
vous avez passé la nuit à essayer
d'arranger la faire parce que et je le
comprends tout à fait il ya d'énormes
intérêts financiers en jeu y compris
pour vous et ça c'est légitime vous avez
essayé de les rabibocher mais vous ne
répondez pas à la question y at il eu de
la sorcellerie dur pur visant à la
destruction d'une candidate par une
autre oui ou non
oui ou non oui oui elle a voulu détruire
bien la série a c'est vrai les abeilles
ont été faites
maintenant ce qu'on veut savoir cf
qu'effectivement c'est sous la
contrainte ont pas mais oui voilà notes
audio qui ont été faites bien évidement
vous les 32 qui contraignent de
l'abandon de la voix hier de la voyante
voilà notre dieu oui pour la voyante a
deux filles en exactement
donc c'est ce que carla dit depuis
samedi matin qu'elle l'a fait sous
influence et là il ya une enquête qui a
été ouverte à marseille et pour répondre
à des accusations gilles non on n'en est
pas là pourquoi parce qu'à ce jour il
est évident que la situation est très
délicate et que carla pour l'instant n'a
pas du tout l'intention de retravailler
donc il n'y a pas d'intérêt financier à
rétablir des cours pour l'instant c'est
très conscient qu'il ya d'intéressant
emma et maija sont quand même très très
remonté c'est logique ils ont entendu
des notes qui sont à 3 sur leurs enfants
pendant des années alors des années il
ya qu'à 2 g
excusez moi les années il ya quelqu'un
qui travaille avec vous et je sais
comment vous travaillez c'est des coups
de fil permanent qui aurait été victime
en versant un million deux cent mille
euros d'extorsion de la part d'une
voyante d'une sorcière et vous n'auriez
pas été au courant
et comme par hasard portes le samedi
alors que tout à fait ressort magali je
vous aime et là vous vous foutez de moi
s'il chutait de moi sa maman m'avait
prévenu il ya quelques mois que carla
était victime de racket est
effectivement là on va y avoir un avocat
allemand n'avait pas je ne savais pas
que tu aies la voyance des choses comme
ça et on l'a encore un avocat oui mais
non et non jerry moyes la police il ya
une enquête qui a été ouverte à la
police de marseille
aujourd'hui qui s'est saisie d'affaires
et qui a activé la brillante à l'as pas
vu qu'elle avoir en contre la voyante
est connu des services de police
défavorablement
et c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà un passé
dans ce genre de problème non mais oui
mais magali déjà leur juste je suis au
pg réussir est ce important
artaud d'aloxi r protection mais c'est
un imbroglio il ya deux problèmes dans
cette histoire il ya à la fois cette
fille qu'est sous influence de cette
dame peut-être de la sorcière mais il ya
aussi l'intention de porter tort de
faire du mal bien sûr ces deux affaires
différentes marseillais deux affaires
différentes qu'elle va demander
publiquement
et ben oui dit que c'était ce qu'on sait
tous on était en dépôt chez grasset sont
complètement
la risée solidarité désolidariser de
carling et on peut le comprendre et
vivre je voulais jouer effectivement
vous l'êtes vous dise moi ce que je
pense moi de cette affaire ouais vous
dire ce que je pense de cette affaire
mais je vous le dire il n'ya pas du
racket 1 dans le milieu de la télé
réalité ont qu un championnat beaucoup à
marseille 1 sur 15 ha
c'est pour ça qu'ils partent tous à
dubaï bien sûr bien sûr c'est à dieu
miles a été agressé devant chez elle
julien et manon un jour ont été agressé
avec une arme à feu il ya eu il ya eu
des choses très graves
est-ce que des knicks mais non mais
sérieusement dira du ramadan mais entre
eux et moi l'enquêté et on m'a dit et je
sais pas si c'est vrai vous allez me
confirmer qu'il y avait aussi pas mal de
deux marseillais qui se faisait
rackettaient à marseille parce qu'il
fait une moue sommateurs de drogue
bah c'est ça et que parce que les gens
qui venaient pour leur fraîcheur de la
drogue chez salans je veux dire la
vérité géraldine j'avais la même version
il paraît que c'est des histoires de
drogue et après comme les footballeurs
d'ailleurs ils sont rackettés de la même
manière et c'est pour ça qu'ils partent
à dubaï parce qu'au moins là bas ils
sont tranquilles je pense que ça c'est
des cdc des fantasmes se sont délitées
public forcément l'agent formation nom
dans le football dans le monde c'est
vrai moi j'ai enquêté j'écris des livres
de si je peux vous dire que ça arrive
mais de surcroît derrière cette histoire
de racket pour essayer de faire passer
la pilule dit la vérité mais c'est mon
chéri à contrecarrer ce que juste et
bien aujourd'hui on se pose tous la
question et on attend et on laisse la
justice faire son travail parce que
c'est regrettable et ça rend triste du
tout le monde mais surtout par rapport à
kevin
parce qu'au milieu il ya quand même une
petite fille il ya kevin karen demander
qui est vraiment aimé un amour
franchement moi fins et c'est eric qui
dépasse aujourd'hui donc et ce qu'elle
voulait cette voyante de carla ses
besoins en argent ou par émises à son
entourage
l argent ou qu'elles nuisent à son
entourage parce qu'elle lui extorquent
de l'argent c'est une chose mais
pourquoi s'est il ya c'est federer de
nuire à son entourage c'est karl a été
décidée serait la voyante bas wifi car
là ça a été fait sous la contrainte et
que ça a été demandé par la voyante la
loi y en n'a ni la taille marquée qui
connaît bien le monde de la voyance et
parce que moi exactement
bien sûr des voyants et c'est vrai qu'on
m'a déjà proposé de faire du du vaudou
sur de certaines sommes donc c'est la
voyante qui vous demande parce qu'ils
savent très bien que c'est c'est un truc
qui demande énormément d'argent
évidemment moi ça m'a jamais intéressé
moi j'ai alors que vous allez voir une
voyante et vous disent que vous avez
les ennemis ou les confins du vaudou non
mais ça m'est déjà arrivé ça m'est déjà
arrivé parce que des fois ça ils
cherchent tellement avons besoin d'avoir
d'argent mais ça c'est des charlottes
chanson up bin voila vont tomber sur
cela c'est des charlatans il faut les
ignorer moi je vais vous parler de
claude alexis oui aujourd'hui la famille
de kevin et carla mais ça détruit aussi
les autres parce que moi non mais par
exemple manon qui ampleur depuis quatre
jours parce que ces essais non mais
lauren ou un vrai drame non mais ça
rigolait pas tous en même temps nathalie
non mais c'est clair que c'est elle qui
a demandé du vaudou cc c'est pas la
voyante à qui a été lui demander
directement les services vocaux le
vaudou sept ans je pense que c'était une
gamine elle avait 17 ans et s'est
laissée entraîner là dedans c'était un
bébé fc plus comment se sortir
maintenant l'érable et je m'intéresse à
voyage à londres 17 ans ouais un premier
avis riante j'ai eu 17 ans j'ai jamais
eu des histoires comme ça moi a confié
je voudrais poser une question mai
dernier un truc là ces grands-mères là
qui vont rester dans tu auras on se met
dans le sens alors vas-y n'amène pas du
tout mais depuis tout à l'heure le noeud
le principal noeud csn voyant 12-10 vous
de vous dites vous-même elle et elle est
toxique elle a un passé alain passif
alors pourquoi on laisse dégénérer la
situation pendant des mois
non qu'on va pas l'avoir pour elle un
peu parce que nous on a été au courant
carla a déposé plainte samedi matin donc
maintenant la justice et la police est
rentrée est en train de faire son
travail nous aujourd'hui on n'a aucune
certitude qu'elle l'a fait sous la
contrainte ou pas et ça allez
marseillais ben alors pour résumer nous
résumer pour nos téléspectateurs
élévateur une audience il ya eu cette
histoire donc carla est allé voir une
voyante pour pratiquer de la sorcellerie
sur une des candidates de télé réalité
qui est avec elle dans les marseillais
qui s'appelle maeva le mec de carla qui
est très sympathique kevin est partie à
dubaï pour parler à my back pour lui
dire de calmer l'histoire dans le même
temps il ya carla qui dit que c'est pas
elle qui a pratiqué la sorcellerie mais
c'est qu'elle était sous influence du
noyau à qui elle a donné un million
trois cent mille euros en 4 1 voilà pour
vous résumer toute l'histoire et qui l'a
forcé donc affaire à pratiquer le vaudou
sur sept autres candidates c'est la
version pour résumer oui les marseillais
maintenant se disent que voilà il ya 2
figure soit elle l'a fait sous
contrainte soit la paf et sous
contrainte à la fait volontairement
elle a besoin des deux et c'est là où
j'en reviens à ça c'est qu'ils sont tous
postés maeva posté un message la
dernière fois en dix ans elle a besoin
d'être aidé parce que quand on fait ça
pendant quatre ans sous la contrainte
c'est qu'on a besoin d'être aidé
maintenant et quand on le fait
volontairement
on va pas se mentir c'est qu'il ya aussi
besoin d'avoir une aide et carla fall en
est consciente elle a besoin d'être
aidée aujourd'hui et c'est ce que les
marseillais vont essayer de frêche
alors bien sûr avec difficulté parce
qu'il y en a qui sont quand même très
très perturbé très touché par ce qui
s'est passé battus besoin d'être aidés
c'est la belle histoire magali besoin
d'être aidée si vous emmène moi aussi je
connais comme nathalie quand vous allez
voir non pas une voyante que vous
trouvez comme ça il y en a sur la place
publique
mais quelqu'un qui fait de la
sorcellerie c'est pas du tout la même
démarche vous pouvez pas ignorer pendant
quatre ans ces volontaires s'est
construit n'est pas être trompée 4 qui
durera 10
alors moi je sais pas si c'est vrai que
c'est faux mais sur sa pathétique vous
expliquer pourquoi moi je comprends pas
vous en tant qu'agent vous avez les
contrats vous savez comment transit
l'argent comment il ya un union virgule
4 qui va sortir des comptes de carla qui
vont aller sur le compte de la voyons
sans trace comme on fait mal là où elle
fit ce qu'on fait en fait la quête fixer
votre employeur mais c'est parce que
vous faites de votre argent
non mais aujourd'hui les gens veulent
savoir je ne sais pas ce qu'elle a fait
200 kg de commencer par dire non
bancaires pour les régions en tant
qu'agent ce n'est pas assez compte
bancaire ça me remet ça avec moi même
comment ils mènent leur carrière mais
sur commande
géraldine je suis désolé mais c'est au
pas savoir dans les comptes bancaires
des candidats moi je vois pas ça moi
j'ai entendu une fois qu'elle avait été
rackettés j'ai prévenu s'est vite
orientée effectivement j'ai appris par
un avocat
voilà après ça a dégénéré aujourd'hui
tout ce que je sais c'est que j'ai déjà
des candidats qui sont traumatisés par
cette situation vraiment par les notes
audio
elles sont garanties qu on va voir la
version wii 68% non à prendre le bon
sens je vais vous dire la vérité
moi je pense que cette histoire ait été
vrai et que voilà bon bout d'un tel
sondage